ce qu'on m'a demandé de faire un
discours
je vous signale tout de suite tous les
dames et messieurs que je vais parler
pour ne rien dire
je sais vous pensez s'il n'a rien à dire
ils feraient mieux de se taire c'est
trop facile
c'est trop facile vous voudriez que je
fasse comme tous ceux qui n'ont rien à
dire et qu'ils le gardent pour eux et
bien non mesdames et messieurs moi quand
je n'ai rien à dire je veux qu'on dise
je vais en faire profiter les autres et
si vous-même mesdames et messieurs vous
n'avez rien à dire eh bien on en a on en
discute je suis pas ennemi du colloque
mais me direz-vous si nous parlons pour
ne rien dire de quoi allons nous parler
d'un de rien de rien car rien j'ai paris
à la preuve assez complet soustraire
rien - rien n'égale moins que rien alors
si on peut trouver moins que rien c'est
que rien vous déjà quelque chose on peut
acheter quelque chose avec rien en
multipliant bon une fois rien c'est rien
deux fois rien c'est pas beaucoup
d'accord mais trois fois rien pour trois
fois rien on peut déjà acheter quelque
chose et pour pas cher maintenant si
vous multipliez trois fois rien pour
trois fois rien rien x rien n'égale rien
3 x trop égale neuf ça fait rien de neuf
alors choses pourront d'autre part l'on
parle de la situation ce n'est pas nous
la situation sans préciser laquelle si
vous le permettez je faire brièvement
l'historique de la situation quelle
qu'elle soit et quelques mois souvenez
vous la situation pour n'être pas pire
que celle d'aujourd'hui n'étaient pas
meilleurs non plus déjà nous allions
vers la catastrophe et nous le savions
nous en étions conscients car il
faudrait pas croire que le responsable
d'hier était plus ignorant de la
situation que le sont ceux d'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ce sont les mêmes oui la
catastrophe nous le pensions et est pour
demain et c'est à dire qu'en fait elle
devrait être pour aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
si mes calculs sont justes
or que voyons nous aujourd'hui qu'elle
est toujours pour demain
alors je vous pose la question mesdames
et messieurs s en remettant toujours au
lendemain la catastrophe que nous
pourrions faire le jour même que nous
les vitres ont
je vous signale entre parenthèses que si
le gouvernement actuel est pas capable
d'assumer la catastrophe
il est possible que l'opposition sont
nos peurs